we choose to go to the moon and district
eight and do the other things not
because they are easy but because they
are hard
[Music]
in any particular sport with
well-defined rules mastery is achieved
through specialization taking a few
skills and perfecting them so naturally
most experts and teachers of movement
are specialists of skillsets like
gymnastics hand balancing Olympic
lifting capoeira Jitsu wrestling judo
and other martial arts so it's rare to
come across a generalist someone who
takes a holistic approach to movement my
guest today is IDO portal he is a guru
of movement a teacher with a large and
quickly growing following as he says
movement is big bigger than any specific
discipline were all human first mover
second and only then specialists I
actually just finished reading a
biography of Albert Einstein by Walter
Isaacson and the two of you have
something in common I desire to arrive
at a unified theory in his case there's
a unified theory of physics you know
like forces of nature in your case it's
a unified theory of movement can you
tell me the story of your journey to
becoming a generalist first I'd just say
that I'm no guru you know it's something
that people use but I have a really hard
time with the word master or guru and I
didn't arrive with the gospel truth I'm
not sitting on any mountains and I'm I'm
on my way
so people who join me as students are
basically following you know in the same
journey maybe in certain circumstances
I'm a bit further ahead or sometimes I'm
a bit behind and but it's definitely
walk along and not walk behind kind of
thing yeah my journey I started as a
mover first and then I became a
specialist and then I went back to
movement basically so yeah it all
started in a young age and some some
Chinese martial arts and developed into
some physical sports and
games in school primary school and high
school and then I met capoeira and I I
was completely amazed basically by this
dis art form and then pursued that for a
good 15 years in the middle somewhere
military service and other physical a
physical pursuit and throughout changing
and developing and moving between
disciplines and exploring just kind of
got the same realization again and again
that there is some thread through all
these disciplines something that is
attracting me back and basically it was
movement I realized and the next thing
was okay I want to learn movement I want
to get better as a mover in a general
way I seeked out a movement teachers and
went around the world and looked around
and read a lot of books and there were
some people who mentioned the word
movement and I went to them and you know
heard myself as a student and they kept
on teaching me disciplines another
isolated approach another speciality and
I was very disappointed so eventually I
decided okay I'm going to become that
person I'm going to become the movement
teacher and the next realization after
years and years of trying was it's
impossible and with that I stayed
basically because I realized if that's
impossible it's a good goal to have in
life something that will keep on moving
myself and my students and anybody
involved forward that's where I'm at
right now I'm in teaching and learning
moving around and trying to try to gain
some more knowledge about this
impossible task yes you're still
yourself or forever a student I would
prefer I prefer to be a student any day
of the week than a teacher and but being
a teacher is part of human culture we
are all teachers we we teach all the
time but whether you want it or not
somebody asks you for direction in
to it you become the teacher you have a
child he looks at you you're a teacher
practicing teaching and practicing to
the student the discipleship both of
them are extremely important for your
development as a movie what is the price
of specialization what do we lose when
we specialize we lose humanity first and
foremost as humans we we evolved to
become humans as generalist we are the
most generalist of all animals we are
able to imitate the ape and imitate the
tiger and and we can hold our breath
underwater and we can do everything just
a tiny bit we can't really run very fast
we can't really fight very well we can't
you know climb as good as other animals
but we can do the most complex and
generalize tasks out of all animals and
no animal even come close
so speciality the price is humanity the
price is your happiness the price is
your fulfillment as a human being it's
deep beats it's philosophical but that's
that's we are do you think there is some
beauty and fulfillment and some value
and specialization in becoming the best
at a very specific movement at a
particular sport giving your body to you
know dedicating it to that sport that's
an interesting thing because as a human
race we benefited tremendously from the
work of specialists but those
specialists suffered that's a very very
important points like without
specialists we would never be here we
would never be skyping right now on
these computers and and you know wearing
these t-shirts and all kinds of stuff
but those specialists those human beings
suffered the result of their highly
specialized nature and we become more
and more specialized the reason move
towards being generalist again in the
last few years maybe the last decade
there is a bit more talk about that but
definitely we are also still
pursuing highly specialized fields if I
make a joke in my workshop and I say
nowadays you go to it if you break your
you know you break your hand you go to a
hand specialist orthopedic surgeon in
five or ten years you'll go to a left
hand specialist
and the most evident problem is also our
leaders who are experts but now they're
required to be generalist leaders of a
lot of stuff and their shitty leaders we
keep on having the same problems again
and again because they are ex
specialists whether it's a lawyer or a
military person or an economist these
are not specialities that allow you the
full grasp of running a country yeah I
think I think you put it beautifully
that in my specialization might lead to
innovation but you lose the humanity mmm
what do you find is the most
underdeveloped range of motion in
athletes like what movement is most
restricted in pi level athletes in your
experience is there any one that stands
out shoulders any particular other
joints well it's it all depends on their
speciality of course in habits the
shoulder the glenohumeral joint is the
most hyper mobile joint in the body even
when it's restricted it still offers
tremendous range of motion compared to
other areas but when it's restricted
even if it's just a little bit it can
cause huge problems because we are
dependent on that range of motion and
mobility around the glenohumeral joint
and the simple reason is because with
the hands humans manipulate that's what
we're meant to do with our hands and we
need that complexity around the scapula
it's been a few years since I've said it
first that the scapula craves complexity
but this complexity around the scapula
and range of motion is so important
across the board
I've read of your concept of isolate in
are graded and improvised okay describe
the role of improvisation in movement
any profession and speciality should
arrive at improvisation in the top and
tier the top level and whether you play
the violin or you know you box you're
going to reach improvisation
improvisation above all is the human
condition it's the human the human
ability the highest form of living is
improvisation you improvise basically
life is improvisation you're born you
die and in between you improvise a
shitload of improvisation movement is no
different the thing is people started to
isolate concept and some people went the
next level and integrated them they
present themselves as improvisation but
actually they're cheating people it's
just a bit more integration yet it's
just another integration improvisation
open improvisation real improvisation as
we call it that's very rare and that's
the most enjoyable state it's also
called the zone it's also called the
tunnel you just experience this
beautiful thing to be empty just to let
things happen through you as Bruce Lee
said I don't hit it hit it just happens
you know and that is improv that's what
you need to do with movement if you
aspire for the highest things I like how
a guy on reddit described you as IDO
portal may not be the nicest guy in the
world
but he's a great coach so that nicest
guy part I come from the wrestling world
where the goal of a good coach and a
good program is to basically make you
quit to break you there's zero patience
for people who don't want to put in the
work to work hard do you find that tough
love is the best approach to coaching
people whatever their level of ability
no not necessarily I don't like the term
tough love because it kind of assumes
the
it's importance is itself it's not
enough for me it's like that's how
that's the best way why that's the best
way but on the other hand I don't think
people are made of sugar and I really
believe that we've lost a bit side of
you know how resilient we are and
another is people don't like the truth
you know it's dishonesty is above all so
when people describe me is tough love
it's not because I believe in Tuffle
100% of the people who has been who have
had issues with me on a personal level
or through coaching are people who
couldn't accept criticism what I offered
you know took it personally weren't able
to deal with it
etc I can't even you know in my head
find one example of a person I've been
working with who received the criticism
worked with it and still complained but
it's always these complainers and who
cares complain first and do
nothing yes yeah yeah you know it's like
when you go mainstream as we've went to
a certain level you have to deal with it
because I'm not operating my elite unit
my Special Op unit anymore now it's an
army and I need to accept the fact that
I'm gonna meet a lot of slackers a lot
of Poindexter's and all kinds of
you know they don't want to work they
want to talk about it they want to do
this they want to do that they don't
want to hear the truth they don't want
to accept criticism or hear how much
they suck and I just don't do that so
you know I'll have to accept the fact
that from now from now and again you
know what I'll have this issue and I'm
sure it will continue you've travelled
all over the world you think there's a
difference in this aspect in attitudes
in the United States and Israel and
other countries big time horse big time
yeah there are many countries where I
don't have this issue or very rarely we
have a word in in Hebrew actually it
comes from Jay
and I think or Yiddish it says touchless
it's like down to it you know the heart
of it tough less people are people who
are like no you know directly
tell me as it is and this stuff less it
it exists in certain cultures in other
cultures it's a lot of chitchat and walk
around and you know I didn't know how to
chitchat a few days ago one of my
students told me you know I can't cheat
you it's exactly how I felt you know
when I first came out of Israel started
to teach around it was Russia thank God
and that was so similar to him where I
come from in many ways so no problem but
then when I went to the US or Canada I
had a lot of issues with the chitchat
with politically correct and walking
around the bush and don't give it to me
too harshly you know cover it with a lot
of sponges around it soft in the heat
and yeah it's definitely different
between various countries and I need
nowadays I need filters which are my my
stood my top students were helping me
teach and some of them are great filters
in and in certain countries they'll do
much better than me what is perfect
practice look like for you so do you
believe in the value maybe this applies
more to specialized sports but like I I
come from Russia actually and from the
wrestling world where repetition you
know putting in ten fifty thousand
hundred thousand repetitions on a
specific movement is is how you achieve
success do you believe in the value of
that repetition even for generalist
framework the repetition is the mother
of skill yes there have been those that
corrected and said perfect repetition is
the mother of skill well those who
usually say it are those who don't
achieve Heights usually usually so I'll
be very frank again I'll be very
extremely honest a lot of people talk
about perfect perfect perfect but but
life is not perfect itself our
surroundings are not perfect and when I
practice and when I move
it's never on the perfect conditions
it's never with the right optimal blood
sugar level and under the specific you
know height of I don't know what and and
riding the wave of super compensation in
the perfect way and usually when people
try to adhere to that concept in a
perfect way they end up falling off the
wagon on the other side don't be don't
be stupid don't just drill yourself into
the wall and lose sight of everything
it's not black and white the truth is
somewhere in between and it varies
between people for me after seventeen
years teaching 18 years now teaching
moving seeing people the hardest workers
are usually the elite performers of
course some of them are carrying a
certain talent or this or that but it's
always with very dedicated practice they
have built up that work capacity through
that dedicated practice and they can
then move that ability to other
disciplines true in a grappling world
I'm not sure how much you're aware of it
but Marcel Garcia is one of the Great's
and he believes boldly against the
status quo I think that you should only
train jiu-jitsu his sport jiu-jitsu and
not do anything else so to achieve
success trained only that but the
majority of other athletes in the sport
believe that you should do strength and
conditioning programs and all around
that so they at least move slightly
towards the more generalist framework
what do you think do you think that's
value for the generalist mindset for
like an elite athlete or should they
just focus on their sport to some level
to some level speciality can can reach a
plateau because of lack of general base
of the pyramid in some cases but it's
not a very high level of you know Janet
generalism nowadays you're you're
practicing against specialists and they
devote more and more time to this
specialty
when you're doing other stuff so it's a
complex rhythm you know and and to each
case his own but I'll tell you something
else when you reach the top of your
field like marcelo garcia did in BJJ you
stopped being inspired by your own scene
you can't gain inspiration knowledge and
motivation from your own scene because
you are the leader you're on top of the
mountain you have nowhere else to climb
so what you do you look to other scenes
and that's where it's really really
valuable to become a bit more
generalized yes you mentioned an
interview related to that a very
interesting point the many people in the
US in particular focus on learning more
than doing so focus too much on
acquiring knowledge versus using that
knowledge do you struggle this yourself
like how do you approach learning new
things versus putting more time into old
things that you've already met Sinead
it's not only a u.s. thing or North
American thing it's generally all across
the globe all those are more practical
people and less practical people you
know in each country has its own
orientation habits you know
characteristics but it's a good question
you need to be it's kind of being super
intelligent and oriented towards the
information but then have this dumbed
down
practical mind it's like okay now I need
to work you know and having a balance
across that and that's probably it that
probably means that you know a certain
IQ for example will start to work
against you in certain fields and vice
versa so you when you become too much
you know as the Chinese say the man who
lives inside his head you start to have
this issue you know you you have a
thirst for information great thirst but
information is toxic
it's exactly like water water is toxic
as well almost all compounds
toxic and then we drink we drink with it
we kill ourselves we kill the process
and the knowledge it turns against us
and that's a serious problem and that's
the problem of the age of misinformation
that we live in it's not only that the
knowledge is toxic even when it's good
knowledge now we also have bad knowledge
mostly bad knowledge mostly shitty
advice the combination is listen just
people become paralyzed or just you know
move from link to link to link with a
you know glazy eyes and just never
actually do anything yes I know you
advocate building a huge word capacity
so how many hours a day do you think
this is also a debate for specialists
how many hours a day do you think is the
most a person can train movement
intelligently before becomes not
sustainable before their mind becomes
uninspired maybe as you said 24 hours 24
hours 24 hours a day there is a
choreographer in Israel very known
choreographer called ohad Naveen he says
when you wake up in the morning in bed
between the sheets you can you can
practice movement and and is not there
talking about with your partner yeah so
even there you can practice you know
breathing moving it's it's all the time
around you but serious practice you know
practice oriented that you know
repetition and success and building
skill and moving from isolation to
integration to improvisation in most
disciplines it's around six to eight
hours a day
some people go more and reach even the
ten hour mark and I've done that for
periods of time in the military you go
even further than that other disciplines
require less and it's also a highly
individual thing so let's say even
within the sports of gymnastics you have
a woman like in Nast who trains eight
hours a day and neck
to her the same team also winning gold
medals at the same level more or less
you have Shawn Johnson training three
hours a day and she reached the top of
her field or liquid gold medal in the
Olympics so how highly individual this
is very rare to see this three hour
gold medal thing but definitely it
exists the difference there might be
mental so the question I have is out of
the various elements like mind breathing
developing muscular strength or joints
which is the biggest challenge to master
as a student a movement highly
individual it depends on the person
depends on is orientation some people
never require any form of mental
training for example or psychological
training especially in fields and like
sports and then team sports yeah so so
that aspect is covered they're winners
they're oriented they're focused you
know and then other people require help
in that regard
some people have great difficulty
developing mobility and just the nervous
system is panicked it holds on it
protects them too much
other people are hyper mobile and have a
difficulty creating tonus and in
strength and that is a great challenge
for them and other people are you know
great complex learners they can name
they can coordinate complex actions and
learn movement very quickly while others
are highly limited so it's very
individual for that process of learning
that journey is individual to everyone
so how does one take that journey just
listen to your own body now now you can
listen to your body until tomorrow
Hypatia you're not hearing anything you
know you're not hearing anything you
need to learn you need to create a
relationship with your body and you need
the help of of teachers right that's
there is only you know a lot of
people say no I'll do it myself then you
deny collective knowledge the most
powerful knowledge that mankind holds
you know because we're the only animal
that have collective knowledge we've
been able to move knowledge across
generations and that's how we have
reached space build the Internet
you know do all these crazy surgeries
and and you know solve you know genetic
issues and etc it's you're not gonna do
it by yourself you're just one small
person and we have collected knowledge
generations upon generations so listen
to your body that's nice to say most
people don't hear it's completely
silent and then you need to start to
decipher the signals that the body gives
you and that goes through a practice and
learning discipleship and exploring a
lot of different different stuff and
it's a highly individual thing nowadays
we don't have so much any anymore this
mentor student or teacher disciple
relationship but I I really believe in
that I wouldn't be here without my
mentors and my teachers the shoulders of
giants that lifted me up I still believe
in it in in a way there is no other way
yeah on that do you think that training
and learning movement for the majority
of the time is a fundamentally solitary
activity or do we gain from like the
presence of others so when you when you
think of movement when you're training
is most of your training like the
repetitions done alone or with others
both and I've trained years you know
alone and with my students and I spend
large periods of time alone just
training alone but I also spend a lot of
time being in a community in movement is
the best reason for gathering around in
a community and you know people for
example nowadays they go do CrossFit or
they do yoga what
ever and then they have their yoga
friends and they have the real friends
that that's you know your yoga
friends can be your real friends because
we've been gathering around movement
since the age of time creating
communities around movement around
hunting gathering dance around the fire
we've been moving together nowadays I
can recommend move with your loved ones
moved with the people around you you
know you join a BJJ Club it's a
community you know you go there you meet
you move around you go to a capoeira
Club it's a tribe you go to a CrossFit
gym it's a community you go to yoga it's
a community you can move with your
children you can move with your dog in
the park and it's important to move
together but it can also be done alone
and some things are better done alone
and some things are better than together
how do you think movement changes from
solo movement you know that that whole
pattern of movement where you're moving
alone versus the pattern of movement
where there's two people either working
together against each other so together
is like dancing partner dancing and
against each other is like wrestling or
jiu-jitsu do you think the principles of
movement are different for when it's two
people versus one person this is a whole
nother world first they spend more time
moving with others against others in
martial art because I spend most of my
life in martial arts and less time
exploring stuff alone but definitely
there are some concepts that still exist
like the quality of movement how you
organize your body in space not in
relation to the partner only but first a
BJJ practitioner or or a stand up
fighter he needs to organize his body in
relation to space first and then in
relation to the partners well so some of
the concepts exist in both while others
are very different and you can train
alone or all your life when somebody
else is in the equation it's going to
change the game completely a major
reason why we are
under the fight laboratory we've
departed in reality from a lot of
traditional martial arts and the
delusions of training alone and doing
forms and and repetitive you know
movements alone and then it's a
shitstorm and you can't apply anything
and you you don't have any live practice
and now we see that and definitely in
the fight game and the practices that
stayed very real stayed very dirty in a
way but very real they are the ones who
are providing tools for the chaotic
environment of a fight terms of injury
how do you treat recover and work around
injury hmm injuries are a certainty
they're not a learnt the probability
injuries and diseases they are also
required as nothing talib one of my
biggest inspirations this day is a great
philosopher and in order to to anti
fragile eyes to become anti fragile to
become robust to become more than
resilient you must be able to enjoy
volatility you must be able to grow from
this stuff and so first I oh I said I
said it before and I'll say it again I
injure my students this happens and I
can do anything beneficial without it
and basically we all get injured
constantly on a micro level a macro
level it's part of our lives of course
we don't want to push into meaningless
injury and we want to be able to grow
from it an in and basically develop from
it how do you train around it how do you
train around it it's a hard question it
involves a lot of stuff first and a big
believer in movement as a therapeutic
tool movement itself if it offers you
adaptation and it does it's the way out
not lack of movement rest
I don't believe in rest I believe in
moving which means when I'm resting
I might help on the short term with
certain aspects of the injury but at the
same time I'm creating a new problem
because there that the adaptive process
is taking me somewhere else
I'm not recovering towards movement I'm
recovering towards no movement so we
have a problem here now in some cases
you must rest and then deal with the
consequences later but in most cases
there is a better approach than just
resting in that that requires a lot more
taking responsibility which doctors
don't believe in your ability to take
responsibility for yourself to be
intelligent and to know the amounts and
the levels and that requires some some
form of a knowledge and experience and
most people can't be trusted with it so
we offer them you know this advice of
like just rest
resting stop yeah but but definitely
after years and years of working with
people and and taking them through crazy
injuries near my right hand or Delia she
she went through a car accident she lost
the kidney she broke her back she went
through three knee surgeries which my
sister performed by the way nowadays she
can move like few people I know on this
planet and and just the answer was
always movement movement going back into
movement beautiful continue move
continue to move yeah don't move
stupidly don't don't hurt yourself but
that's an obvious no I guess not because
when I say these things people write a
comment the but the bad people
you know yeah but you're gonna injure
yourself yeah genius
haha don't go into the injury and and
again deteriorate the escalate the
situation of course not you must move
around it and you must be smart in the
way that you allow adaptation to take
you out like a wave you need to ride the
wave of adaptation out of the out
the problem and that's tricky we know
and that's something that we need to
educate people on and we need to believe
in people's intelligence and ability to
take this responsibility in China where
they still have in some areas and they
used to have bone setters they didn't
put you in a cast you broke your hand or
they they did it through bone setting
and yes they didn't have x-ray so that's
a lot more complex to do and not as
successful as nowadays but having said
that they did achieve amazing rates of
recovery because these reps that they
use and the process allows some form of
movement and that creates an adaptation
now take an arm a healthy arm your right
arm put it in a cast for six months take
it down the cast what do you see the
observer the arm is basically moving
towards death yes
it's gotten good at not moving the arm
is great you have weird hairs growing
out of it it stinks it really smells and
looks like death because movement is
life no movement death
we know that we like to just kill your
arm a tiny bit so that so the bones can
reform together and then we'll bring it
back to life that's one approach but in
other cases you can maintain the life
and the demands on the tissue safely
enough at the same time allow the
recovery to happen yes and diet what are
some diet principles you follow
well diet is very individual thing I've
been personally following a Paleolithic
a caveman diet for a long time long
before it was called the Paleo diet and
since 1997 or even 96 I've been doing
this for a long time I feel great on it
still you know growing older and older
and
functioning only better and being able
to sustain maintain improve but that is
very very individual there is a lot of
exploration to be done there what you
can withstand how resilient is your
system yes nowadays there is a new
movement towards not improving the fuel
sources not improving the quality and
the quantities of the food but actually
making the system more resilient so it's
able to basically withstand any almost
any quality and source and that's where
we have been lacking and we will be
neglecting this area and that's
something that and I believe is the
latest innovation although it's still
highly misunderstood and a lot of a lot
of folks are abusing this concept and
giving really poor advice just to be
different just to say I'm not the paleo
guy you know so that's that's a small
addition that will get bigger and bigger
I think so it's almost like how you
recommend a movement to go outside of
quote-unquote proper alignment this is
kind of the diet version of that is
going outside of some kind of proper
framework of diet to some level but
that's so that was an obvious thing you
know always right the problem is it's
not enough because in fact it's more
what I'm suggesting with movement to go
outside of the proper alignment
it creates an adaptation but what if
that adaptation cannot happen for
example a celiac disease person you'll
expose him to gluten and you'll have
terrible consequences now maybe if you
can minimize enough the amounts and the
dosages you can actually train him out
of tell yak to some level but death
adaptational last very very far down the
road
he's going to get some gains and then is
going to plateau but what if you could
take that celiac disease person
put them in the garage fix his
mechanisms change his tires change his
engine you know oil him up everything
and then put him back on the track as a
new animal and that that is where you
know a lot of stuff is happening
nowadays so the genetic part of it and
the gut biome and our digestive tract
that is is so so complex and and we
discover that you know we live in
symbiosis with all these microorganisms
that just are all over skin inside of us
and we live in combination with them and
that's how you see some dudes in Brazil
and in Russia walking around with you
know 5% body fat eating one cracker for
breakfast one cracker for dinner and you
know training BJJ all day long
high-performance fueling with coca-cola
and then at the same time you see people
doing everything almost perfectly and
still having poor poor performance and
inability and they gain weight with any
you know extra calorie or macronutrient
that they brought in because their
system is different and it's not only
about genetics it's more about
epigenetics and it's more about what
kind of system besides your own DNA what
about these organisms that are supposed
to help us and live in symbiosis with
you what kind of a system do you have
there and that's just two areas and I
think it's going to get it's going to
expand more and more in work and we're
going to realize that there is a lot to
learn there do you think technology and
science is ultimately a positive force
for you know you look at movement as as
an element of our humanity do you think
technology is taking humanity away or
it's adding to it I'm not smart enough
to answer you that man yeah it's a big
question you know
it's a I have no idea it's just it's a
huge question and I think we're going to
struggle with that question for many
generations to come still it definitely
created a lot of positive stuff but also
brought tremendous suffering and
problems and perhaps will be the you
know the end of us so technology might
have been you know the most terrible
thing that ever happened to us
who knows yes that beautiful no how can
people join the IDO portal movement if
you have a website a hero portal calm
yeah IDO portal calm in phase B we are
on facebook you can find us on Facebook
they do aim it or portal method a little
portal I do P ort al you can join the
movement culture on our website and that
will lead to some updates coming up soon
you have a beautiful website by the way
amazing thanks very much
hey thank you very much I've been a very
fortunate to have a great team around me
that helped me with that
so I saw that you posted a couple of Tom
Waits songs and I even a Bukowski
reference on your Facebook page and I
immediately understood something that I
think only another fan or maybe I should
say student of weights and Bukowski can
understand you don't shy away from the
strange and the profound wherever you
can find it maybe that's how one way to
put it
is there a Tom Waits song that you find
yourself returning to often in your life
mmm so many man so many is just that Tom
way you know I I can barely listen to
anything else frankly it's been a real
issue and Tom Tom Waits is his
discography it's like it it's a lifetime
of discoveries I I it's been
accompanying me for years now it's not
only it's not you know it's not
something you go through very quickly
and I've spent a lot of time on Alice
for example and
yeah just so much stuff so much that's
always discover also you know I I find
this this weirdness this is eccentric
part of things it's so important it's
the only thing really that can be you in
many ways because as a culture
we're so blend we're becoming this one
thing you know like you walk around in
London it looks exactly like Hong Kong
it looks exactly like Tokyo it looks
exactly like you know Sydney and we have
this like huge human thing going on
which is great and we communicate very
easily but then we lost a lot on our our
own stuff there is only one Tom Waits
you know because of his eccentric part
because of his you know this this weird
genius and that's why it's so beautiful
to me and then I try not to not to shy
away from my own eccentric side and when
I was younger I I definitely hit that
part more and you know you know guarded
and try to try to be to fit in but
that's definitely an important thing I
think so you recommend we cultivate the
weird yeah yeah cultivating the words
cultivating yourself because that that's
truly you you know everybody's weird
everybody there is no Homer Simpson you
know and everybody has this bar
everything he'll everybody has this
interesting stuff that's what also
interests me when I teach I want to see
that weird you know I want to see that
weird in your movement I want to see
that weird in you and that then I really
met you but most people they hide it and
they don't a lie and they put this
perfect picture but it well I'm not
stupid
I know it's not perfect you know so just
allow the weirdness to come out I think
it's a great lesson yeah from-from
weights and and Bukovsky as well or so
if you don't mind I'm gonna torture you
or something I would like to close by
reading a Bukowski poem roll the dice
I want to force you to listen to it go
ahead
if you're going to try go all the way
otherwise don't even start this could
mean losing girlfriends wives relative's
jobs maybe your mind
it could be not eating for three or four
days it could mean freezing on a park
bench
it could mean jail it could mean
division it could mean mockery isolation
isolation is the gift all the others are
a test of your endurance of how much you
really want to do it and you'll do it
despite rejection and the worst odds and
it will be better than anything else you
can imagine if you're going to try go
all the way there's no other feeling
like that you will be alone with the
gods and the nights will flame with fire
you will ride life straight to perfect
laughter it's the only good fight there
is amen thanks al thanks for talking to
Daymond thank you so much man for